hi guys
today i'm back with another game for you
and it's a really really cute one
i had been waiting for this for ages and
for some reason i didn't even realize
when it came out and it's been out for a
few months now it's called a bird story
it is made by the same person who made
to the moon
if you've ever played to the moon then
you know how cute
and wonderful and emotional the game is
so i'm expecting great things in this
game it's not a sequel
but it's supposed to be just as
emotional
and just as atmospheric as to the moon
okay he's just looking inside the tree
that makes
sense
paper airplane
wow
i want to see if i can make one like
that i'm terrible at them
so
i love his patchwork sheets
look it looks just like to the moon
which is a good thing
wake up
no nope
oh are we in dream world
okay oh what
it's my shadow why am i walking
backwards i guess it's a dream nothing
makes sense in dreams
oh okay so i'm just following my shadow
oh this is paper airplane can i fly it
ah awesome look at me can i go forward
oh that's strange
this happens when i go forward a little
person walks out
it's odd okay
wait um no can't go forward
oh look it's me go back into me
all right now's in school
everyone's shadows
this is an awful dream
i'm so glad i'm not in school anymore
oh
hey that's something nice
he made it pinch the teacher's butt oh
wait it's going slow motion it's so
dramatic
look at the cats
oh hit her head
and see the cat boom boom
mean
ah
so
ah
i like how it transitions oh look
he's got a little rucksack on did he
have that on before
probably probably just don't notice
anything
this is my little walk home walking home
from school
wow is this my house
hotel oh i see
oh he's so sure he has to jump up to it
that's so cute
i still have to do that now not with
elevators
luckily
awkward elevator glances
goodbye
oh is that noise that noise is
everywhere in these games
means that some mysterious stuff is
about to happen
which way should we go this way
where's his parents
ah they left him a note okay so he can't
be living on his own he's like 12.
hey i can't even read it okay
fine i'm guessing she's out buying me
some ben
jerry's
what's on the bed what
were they reading oh oh i see i can only
interact with the sparkly thing so that
makes total sense why didn't i
oh it's just a light
so i can look at this telescope
i love the music what is he doing
there's no point in peering out there
what oh
oh bless
oh it's his bedroom what a modest little
flat
oh there's so many letters on his desk
does that mean that his mom's never in
that's sad
oh he's hungry
okay let's go make you some food young
man
oh where's his parents i'm getting
worried about him
okay now he's ready for his book
what's the book about
i'm just going to make his paper
airplane
is he throwing it to his mum maybe oh
no he's just playing with it fair enough
oh oh we fell over
oh
oh i see he's probably doing his
homework isn't he
boring
okay sleepy
oh i have so many questions
it's okay they'll get answered soon i
think i hope
oh he's still asleep at his desk
bless him
okay so his mom came in in the end and
put like a little blanket over him
all dad one of them mom and dad my mom
and dad
but what an equipment bed
turn off oh okay that worked
why is it glowing oh
bum
go to the toilet turn off the lab nope
can't do anything
okay another note
oh he's his bag
there you go he still looks really
sleepy
uh he needs his homework oh yeah you
stayed up all night doing that homework
you can't leave it
oh fabulous homework absolutely fabulous
i give you a star
oh breakfast
cupcake for breakfast nice choice
it's going to be raining take the
umbrella
good boy
oh what a rebel
what a rebel i'd take the umbrella if i
were you you get cold oh my gosh
be careful
ah this school is near
oh this is my seat
oh i stood up too late doing that
amazing homework
he's so tired
hey teacher she's going to be angry now
she hasn't
he hasn't been listening to her
oh how very rude
just kicked him over the wall how was
that even possible
okay have one question was this way
um nothing absolutely nothing let's just
go back this way
okay so it's raining just like his mum
dad
whoever strange mysterious figure told
him
and he doesn't have his umbrella
you're gonna get soaking
oh yeah jefferson butters
that's jumping in the burner
okay so he doesn't mind oh man
make a splash make a splash make it
splash
come on jump
can i jump in this armpit jumper snap it
no i can't
oh what it is to be a child again
before i still like to do this now but
it's more socially acceptable oh what's
this
and let's go
oh no get away from me
badger
oh he's so brave look at him
so this is the bird
oh poor little thing
can't fly and it's scared
i don't want to leave him
no he doesn't want to scare him
okay fine poor little thing
oh no it's back again
you beat him up oh what
did he just get inside the rock that he
threw or was
oh it's his bag oh he got inside his bag
oh it's so cute
he doesn't know that he's in there
surely he should feel some rustling
okay
oh that's so cute
oh wow i like that
oh oh okay wherever you tell me to go
ends
i shall go
oh good idea yes definitely taking him
to the vets
hmm no one's in
oh well looks like i'll just have to
take him back home then
nope how do i get him
where am i going i don't think i was
supposed to go here
where am i going okay this way
oh i should have gone that way
okay
no pets allowed it's okay he's a
big rebel anyway he already said no to
taking an umbrella outside
we're safe elevated ladies is mine does
she
it's a good chick we're nearly home
chick duck yeah
it's all still the same
hmm
oh he's home alone again it's kind of
cute this time though because he gets
his duck wait what am i doing
is is sorting his hair out
can i see it this time please nope
no way okay let's take him straight
to the bedroom
where should i put you oh here
come on
what do you want to get him some water
good idea i was thinking breadcrumbs as
well
water and breadcrumbs where's your sink
is this your sink oh bathroom got goya
oh yes let's go give some water to the
bird
so cute so cute
come here party
yes yes this is only what i was thinking
yay oh he's so happy
hello where's he going
he's in the tree no he's in the tree he
must be
i knew it look at him
hmm
oh it's so hmm i got it oh i just can't
come oh it's just too
too cute too cute
what am i doing now ah
eat your bread
so cute
oh be careful peaceful
oh he's lonely
oh bless
it's a lonely boy and a lonely bird
is he gonna take him to school
oh what's this now
that's awesome
i wish you could do that in real life
that would be awesome
i love the music it's okay
oh here we go right okay let's try again
we'll get that wing of yours fixed
he doesn't have any money though does
she expect money
let's get in the water i am now
an assistant
a vet assistant
bandages where's where's bandages
oh my god i'm blind okay
they're not here that makes a lot of
sense
is she gonna fix him
it will take more than just one vet
visit surely
yeah it's gotta heal
bird is all better yay
just give them a couple days
what's that
what does she just think
oh a bad cage
really
yeah he's like no no bird cage
oh did you want to keep the bird there
oh it's his bird
one day
he's so cute
still have not seen his mom or dad
where are they
ah little red hat cute
it's dog
what's this
fetch it good bird
no no you gotta give it back no
stupid bird
so cute though can't stay mad at you
oh look where we've ended up a living
room in the middle of
the forest how convenient
oh they're my best buds it's so cute
oh that's adorable
he takes an umbrella when he wants to
take care of the birds
but jumping in puddles is still much
more fun
wait what are we like are we having a a
puddle jump wall
oh dear you're on right let's do this
i'm so gonna win no i'm gonna win
come on i got a jumper oh no i'm gonna
lose to a bird i won
yes oh he's l
my birthday oh stay awake
you ready bird you're gonna break it
back this time go
bring it back oh ah
tease oh look at you go
i plus speaking
where did you go come back here
oh ice cream
can birds eat ice cream okay apparently
so
that's
look at adorable ducks
i don't know
what's everyone doing leave us alone
it's okay we can fly
to the moon
oh this is so feel good i can't ah
too many happiness
ah oh
you're such a good bird
oh this is adorable
aha bread for my bread please
there we go
you gotta buy it first you can't just
walk out
okay
okay follow my shadow
where did you go
oh this is where i first found the bread
yeah good times
i'm just gonna find his mom
what is this mom isn't it
what's he gonna do is he's gonna take
the bag back
but it's his best friend
oh wow they're on the roof
once upon a time there was a little bird
that bird's name was george oh oh okay
is he gonna make a big airplane
hmm
oh
it's so cute
no way would it say that
then again it wouldn't actually hold
their weight either so i'll just shut up
let's go where are we going
i'm so speedy where are we going
out into the countryside
oh it looks so pretty oh what is this
nope it's not happy here
too snowy
what about by the ocean
it's a fancy island
nope far too fancy for this duck
chicken whatever bird what am i
what am i calling it
oh dear
what is this deserty
not right far too hot
i think i think i've established you
don't like hot places
i'm not too fond of hot places it's
quite rare to find
someone that isn't
now
definitely on your eggs one more nest
you've got to like this one
we'll find the perfect home for you
oh this place is nice
where's the where is it
there it is
no you make any of them
but that was all of them
ah far too fussy
i made this big paper airplane to find
you a home
and you didn't like any of them
oh it's okay i'll save it for later
apparently
oh
in my mind that was hey wait yes i love
you
oh is that mom
mom where have you been
wait it's not the vet lady
is it is mom the vet lady no
i think i'm just getting confused
oh it's hiding her
it is the bad lady isn't it and she
wants to take my bird
but i don't want to take my bread
hmm
oh this is getting so confusing but in
like a really good way
huh no one's in class oh no
i'm ripping to encounter music
actually don't even know about it
what are the be a duck
become a duck
he's gonna jump over there
he's mario love it
who's this is that him
it's that noise again it's not the same
kind of dream noise
into the moon
it's oddly creepy like it'll go from
being really cute and funny to
really kind of weird and creepy
i like that
we buried it
how's your wing doing can you fly it
no oh
oh he's sad
time to school yay
take your umbrella
can i jump nope it's not one of those
happy moments
why is it all sad is it just because
he's worried about the
about the bird
oh he's gonna give the bird back
so that you can get better
oh don't do that that's so sad
don't do that
what
why is she abusing him like that
what
good what is wrong with these people
i'm so confused oh i've gotta
okay gotta go
it's getting all dramatic intense
oh no
ah
oh nice then i'm gonna make it and i'm
gonna make it
oh
go
you can't die though
where's the bird
his backpack
oh no which way should they be
oh here we go
is that him no that can't be him
he's a shadow oh no
what just happened
did it die no what
what just happened
i don't care about people i want to know
if my bird's okay i'm confused
he did die to me it was his little body
that the other one was taking away
should i post it
no i can't
it's the same woman at the elevator
every single time
does she just wait for me oh wait i
don't need to press a person
so
now he's gonna go back into his lonely
house
where his mom is never in
read the stupid note on the fridge
no bird
oh so that's why he was looking in his
tree at the beginning
is that just in case it ever comes back
what boys
force of habit
um
wait
wake up
back to the beginning now isn't it
that's what happened at the beginning
and then he went to sleep and then
time of rest oh i got here and then we
played in this past okay
you're live oh my gosh mommy see you
look i found a mate
you can fly
so happy for you
okay i'll remove the band
much better
you take care of him
oh
such a clever bird
hmm
oh makes me want a bird
i have to let him go okay three
two one
love's adorable
it's so cute too you do handle
so emotional okay
very cute though
they found a nest that they liked
oh look at them
oh i like that island it looks pretty
a little extra bite
oh
finding paradise
coming one day
free bird games amazing games
so cute
just the music as well oh so good
right i hope you enjoyed this one i know
it was a long one
but i couldn't stop playing and it's
only a short game
i absolutely love that game free bread
games always make me kind of
emotional and happy and sad and
i just enjoy every second of them that
the art style is amazing the music is
amazing
the narrative is amazing this what is
not to love
if you like this video please leave it a
like i really appreciate it
and have a lovely day or evening bye
you